resident evil village is filled with
secrets and hidden references
but did you find them all so i'm going
to play a game with you all
i want to play the game i'm going to go
over 22 things you might not have known
from residence evil village
if you missed even one thing go ahead
and hit that like button
but if you learn nothing hit the dislike
button guilt free
oh and there will be major spoilers
[Music]
this isn't going to end well for me is
it i'm going to start with an easy one
because it's fun and well i like it for
those of you who play resident evil 4
you might have noticed just how similar
the introduction is you meet a couple of
enemies who you have to fight off
when suddenly you're swarmed by an
overwhelming number of them
just around the time you find the
shotgun but the connections don't stop
there after meeting resident evil
village's merchant the duke
he might at one point drop the following
line
what are you buying just something an
old friend of mine used to say
the friend who he's referencing is of
course the infamous merchant from
resident evil 4.
what are you buying now for those of you
who haven't played resident evil 4
why are you still watching this video go
play r4 here hold on hold on
i have this alphabetical order it should
be pretty easy to find
what there you go go play re4
it is excellent george trevor is the mad
genius behind the resident evil mansion
if you play the original game and ever
wondered who would design such a crazy
mansion with secret chambers and crazy
keys everywhere
look no further than this man and in
resident evil village
we learned where he might have gotten
his inspiration in the very beginning of
the game you can find a book on the
architecture of eastern european castles
written by none other than george trevor
himself
another notable mention about george
trevor is that his daughter
lisa actually appears in the 2002
gamecube remake of the original game
just you know slightly affected by the
progenitor virus
another book you can find in ethan
winter's home is gun survivalist
a heavy firearms manual for field combat
situations
written by joseph kendo joseph kendo
being a relative of the gunsmith robert
kendo
who shows up in the resident evil 2
remake and resident evil 3.
you know how in resident evil village
you have to attack and collect all the
go figures
well resident evil 7 did the same thing
but with bobbleheads of the legendary
sports figure
mr everywhere what team is he on
i don't know but digging further into
ethan's european home
you'll spot yet another bobble head of
the legendary sports figure
i was pretty sure i destroyed all these
in re7 but i guess ethan secretly snuck
one into his
massive massive pockets notably if you
bought the deluxe edition there's also a
mr everywhere weapon charm you can equip
as it turns out ethan's house is filled
to the brim with easter eggs and hidden
references
another one of these lies within the red
wine neopore's ethan
while i later attributed this wine to
being one of lady demetres wines
as it turns out the wine is labeled
regina rose
this is romanian and in english it
translates to red queen
this is particularly significant if you
ever watch paul w s
anderson's film uh resident evil
the red queen is the primary ai
antagonist of the 2002 film
and the name even appears again in
resident evil umbrella chronicles
speaking of lady dimetresk as far back
as 11 months ago
redditor gabriel mora noted that the
castle dimetresk seemed to resemble the
real world location pele's castle
more recently redditer's smooth skin
operator showed everyone side by side of
the striking similarity to the castle
located in brehova county romania as
medieval as the castle looks
construction actually began in 1873 and
completed in 1913.
this is a little different than the 15th
century origins from the winemaking
castle of the game
but visually the inspiration is
definitely there
something you might have noticed from
the last two points are references to
romania
in the game we're never told exactly
where ethan and mia have been relocated
outside of somewhere in europe it's just
finding you in louisiana the pregnancy
chris moving us here military training
it all happened so fast
given all the evidence it seems pretty
clear the game takes place in romania
for starters the wine i mentioned
earlier regina rose
is romanian and of course there's the
fact that castle dimitrescu seems to be
inspired by the real world pele's castle
of romania
but beyond that the soup that me and
ethan are eating at the beginning of the
game
is choba de la gum or romanian sour soup
on top of that the ever popular lady
demetresque's last name
is actually romanian in origin and uh
not pronounced the way it's pronounced
in the game
romanian pronunciation would have this
as dimitresco
of course lady demetresque is incredibly
similar to vampire and her appetite for
blood with dracula
of course being from transylvania
romania going further the currency of
the game is the lay
which is the same currency used in
romania there's also elizabeth bathory
who is a hungarian noblewoman who owned
land in the kingdom of hungary
which is now divided by hungary slovakia
and romania
and how does she fit in well elizabeth
bathory
is very likely the direct inspiration
for alcena de metresque
bathory born in 1560 and who died in
1614
was known to be a sadistic serial killer
which is evidenced by the testimony of
over
300 witnesses and survivors
and a horribly mutilated dead dying and
imprisoned girls
and hey wasn't it lady dimitrisk who set
up a torture chamber where she
very specifically only hired females to
work for her in her castle
and then proceeded to torture experiment
on and turn into marika
not only that but folklore and tall
tales say that she even
bathed in the blood of virgins to retain
her youth which reminds me of a certain
wine bath in her hall of ablution
ablution being the act to wash oneself
there's also the whole thing where lady
demon dress needs to eat human flesh in
order to retain her ability to
regenerate
and thereby stay youthful okay so you
made it past the first encounter with
the lords
met up with the duke and are now in
castle dimitresque now that you're here
why not stay a while play some music on
the piano
experience the wonderful decor and take
a quick trip
via your face smashing into the floor to
one of the many dungeons
in the first of these you encounter just
past the secret door hidden behind a
relief wall
you'll discover a note about various
victims experimented on
of the four candidates who made it and
weren't rejected one of these
is ingrid who's later noted as unstable
overly alert at times
killing various maraca nearby one will
drop ingrid's necklace
confirming that the staff and women who
were delivered to houston etresque were
given cadets and turned into these
marika
but that's not the only connection with
ingrid the ps5 demo of resident evil
village
maiden where you're told to escape the
dungeon of house demetresque actually
has you playing as ingrid
while lady dumatresk is a favorite
villain from resident evil village
as someone who's always been terrified
of ghosts and ventriloquist dummies
donna beneviento and angie easily won as
my favorite
and when i wasn't covering my eyes in
horror there were a couple details about
donna's doll angie that stood out
for one donna has scarring on her face
that has left her shy and timid
we briefly see donna's face when she
dies and her kadeau placement on her
face looks suspiciously similar to
angie's markings
making it likely to me that this doll
her father made for her is supposed to
represent her
and have similar scarring so she would
have a playmate but that's just
conjecture so let's talk about something
we definitely know
taking an even closer look at angie's
face
you'll notice that her scarring is
nearly identical to the beneviento sun
and moon crest
this was done intentionally and looking
at the concept art of angie it's
even more clear speaking of dolls this
portion of resident evil village is
actually inspired by a previous resident
evil game
resident evil 3.5 okay so that isn't an
official name it's just the one that
fans gave it
while making resident evil 4 the game
ran into multiple development hurdles
in fact the first devil may cry was
actually going to be resident evil 4
before shinji mikami decided hideki
kamiya's vision for the game differed
too much and should be its own original
franchise
so the game underwent even more
variations including the fog version
a hookman version and a hallucination
version
before finally landing on the resident
evil 4 we all know and love today
but going back to that hook man version
i mentioned earlier
in this version leon fought off against
paranormal enemies
a ghost man with a hook and even more
notably
living dolls while the doll connection
is
clearly there
[Music]
to go deeper into house beneviento the
original concept was that the beneviento
family were supposed to be ghosts who
all had a tragic backstory the
entire section is a nod to this version
of resident evil 4
and frankly it just makes me wish we had
an entire game built around the concept
continuing on with donna beniviento when
you're in the beneviento basement you
can find an orange box within the
laboratory room that's next to me is
doll
this is the same orange box that can
regularly be found in the baker's state
of resident evil 7
which always had helpful items inside
sadly
this one can't be opened when you
finally encounter heisenberg's crazy
board you can take some time to look in
at his photos before pulling away the
curtain and triggering his cutscene
here every major lord you've defeated
has a giant x along their picture
indicating their demise you can also
spot photos of mia
rose and chris redfield interestingly
mia hasn't been
xed out here and on first playing i sort
of just assumed this was because she
wasn't a major lord
but heisenberg is pretty savvy to what's
been going on
even knowing the bsaa are on their way
so
it draws the question does heisenberg
know that mia is actually still alive
this could actually be our first hint as
to that because it does seem likely she
too would have been crossed out
this is another quick reference to a
previous resident evil game but a fun
one
when fighting against heisenberg he says
the following in reference to chris
redfield
heisenberg deeming chris a boulder
punching [ __ ] is a reference to
resident evil 5
where chris uh yeah he punches a giant
boulder into lava
never stop being ridiculous resident
evil while lair used to purchase weapons
of items in resident evil village
resident evil 7 had special anti-coin
collectibles that could be found and
used to purchase special items
we can find another anti-coin in a cave
near the end of resident evil village
paying yet another homage to the seventh
main entry into the franchise
as it would turn out miranda secretly
had a lab where she was conducting
experiments using the kadosh she created
in order to try and revive her daughter
back from the dead
her lab we find as chris redfield bears
a striking resemblance to none other
than david's secret lab of alien
covenant
where he somewhat similarly was focused
on combining aliens with humans
keeping continuity in the series all the
way back to the very first resident evil
game with live action cutscenes
after learning about ethan winter's
supposed death chris redfield lights his
cigarette in distress
this is the same as the actor who
portrayed chris redfield did in the
original game
who does so in the bad ending after he's
failed to save everyone else
this case was just too weird
this case was another quick one but a
good one
in mercenaries mode of resident evil
village you'll stop by the duke's room
in between missions
to me his song sounds like a merger of
the iconic safe room theme from the
first resident evil game
and resident evil 4 safe room theme take
a listen
[Music]
while i wouldn't call this one difficult
to spot some of these are more
oh yeah that makes sense in retrospect
there's plenty of hints early on that
ethan is actually a mold monster
for one the fact that he's somehow able
to put his hand back on
and have it function after getting
chopped off why every enemy focuses on
destroying his hands in this game
i don't know but at the very least that
scene
now makes sense but there's another
couple hints snuck in there early on
the first comes from lady dimitrisk
trying ethan's blood
hmm starting to go a little sting
uh excuse me but my mold blood is the
highest of quality
thank you very much not only that but
when speaking to mother miranda
disguises the old hag
she'll riddle to ethan i almost died up
at that castle
tell me what is going on around here
how can a man be almost dead
that's a question for the wise oh
because because he's a mold monster how
did i not pick that up
again another minor one but if there's
one defining feature about ethan winters
it's his sweet
sweet jacket and after he sacrifices
himself to save rose and the world
he wraps her up in this jacket at the
very end of the game when the now
teenage rose goes to pay respects to her
father
she's actually now wearing his jacket so
i mentioned before that there were some
similarities to resident evil 4 at the
beginning of the game
but now that we're through it it's worth
bringing up that resident evil 4 served
as a
major inspiration for the game producer
tsuyoshi kanda stated that resident evil
village was going to be a version of
resident evil 7 that inherited the dna
of resident evil 4.
the entire structure of the game was
built with the essence of resident evil
4 in mind
so for any similarity you find it was
probably
intentional so remember how at the end
of resident evil village ethan
heroically sacrifices himself to both
save his daughter and to protect the
world from the mega mice by
pretty much blowing himself up with an
insane explosion cementing that he is
indeed finally dead
well uh you can actually spot him again
with photo mode later on in the game
with a special camera mod
to be crystal clear i played the game on
ps5 and i don't own it on pc
so i couldn't test it out myself and
there's the chance that there's an
additional mod going on here i'm unaware
of
even though i don't think there is
there's the chance
at the very end of the game after a
teenage rose winters is escorted away in
a car
that very same car slows down as a man
approaches it
using photomode to zoom in on this man
it turns out to be
none other than ethan winters with
much more of a face than his concept art
so this begs
the question what exactly is going on is
this a foreshadow that ethan will in
some way return in the next resident
evil game
or is it some sort of mold monster
taking his form
or is it just the developer saving money
on making extra assets and using one
they already had as the character was in
the distance and you weren't supposed to
be able to see him
i guess we'll find out in resident evil
9
or dlc so there are 22 things you might
have missed from resident evil village
is there anything in particular that
stood out to you or that i missed that
you think i should have included
let me know in the comments below and i
am afraid
to look at the like dislike ratio why
did i do this to myself
[Music]
you